three aurora colorado police officers
and two paramedics have been indicted on
manslaughter and other charges in the
death of 23 year old elijah mclean now
this indictment comes two years after
mclean was put into a choke hold and
injected with a powerful sedative last
year nationwide protests against racial
injustice and police brutality brought
increased attention to mclean's death
our national correspondent that's jerica
duncan spoke to his family
i have a right to stop you because
you're being suspicious
twenty-three-year-old elijah mcclain's
pleas for protection and understanding
were ignored by the officers who
arrested him after they received calls
about a suspicious person
mclean was walking home from a
convenience store
when he was saying i'm just different we
i had everything in my power as a single
mom to make sure he wasn't a statistic
he really was innocent he didn't do
anything wrong his mother shanine
mcclain says her son was a kind soul who
loved to play the violin since his death
two years ago she's been praying for
justice he was a son
a nephew
a brother and a friend
wednesday colorado's attorney general
announced a 32-count indictment against
two current and one former police
officers and two paramedics involved in
mclean's death
according to the indictment mcclain was
rendered unconscious suffered hypoxia or
lack of oxygen and his physical and
mental condition were impaired after
officers placed him in several carotid
holds when paramedics arrived they
injected him with ketamine a drug used
to sedate combative people but the
dosage they administered was meant for
someone more than 70 pounds heavier
mclean was rushed to the hospital later
declared brain dead and taken off life
support at first the district attorney
declined to file charges in 2019
citing inconclusive evidence but as
mclean's death gained nationwide
attention after the death of george
floyd
colorado's governor in june of 2020
designated the attorney general to
investigate mclean's death we recognize
that this case will be difficult to
prosecute
these types of cases always are
done despite no evidence showing it
police claim mclean reached for one of
the officer's gun the police union said
in a statement our officers did nothing
wrong and claimed the charges were part
of what it called the hysterical
overreaction to this case his parents
disagree what does justice look like
to you you can't bring my son back but
we can hold them accountable if those
three police officers and two paramedics
are watching right now what do you want
them to know that they don't deserve the
uniforms that they were wearing that
night
they don't deserve to be in the field
that they're in because they disrespect
life
the aurora colorado city manager said in
a statement that the employees have been
suspended without pay pending the
results of the case one of the officers
was fired last year after he texted
photos mimicking the chokehold used that
day the firefighters union representing
the two paramedics said it is standing
by the legal process it's worth noting
that it is rare for officers to be
charged but even more rare for
paramedics to be prosecuted this is just
a horrible story all the way around and
having spoken to both parents last night
it's obvious that they're still
heartbroken there's nothing that's going
to bring their son back
and then to hear i think from the union
you know saying there's no evidence that
the officers caused this death and that
this was
folks being hysterical and overreacting
doesn't doesn't you know help at one
point one official said it was because
he violently resisted arrest and i
remember this story very well because of
his final words which i pulled today he
said in part i have no gun i don't do
stuff i don't do any fighting why are
you attacking me i don't even kill flies
i don't eat meat i don't judge people
then he says you're beautiful i love you
oh i'm so sorry i just can't breathe
correctly you could tell this was a
different kind of person number one he
weighed 140 pounds i weigh 169 so i was
struck by that that i weighed more than
him and the amount of of uh the chemical
that was given to ketamine ketamine was
so much stronger than was necessary you
could tell by just listening to him we
all saw the tape
very hard different he said he said i'm
different i'm sorry yes i'm an introvert
and he was wearing a mask because of uh
his asthmatic condition and anemia
yeah the police got a call so they
wouldn't check it out they checked it
out i don't understand how the checkout
went from hey what's going on where are
you coming from to everyone on the
ground yeah their argument is he was
restraining and he was scared he wasn't
guilty of anything there's a guy walking
around the street the police officers
also claimed that he said
or tried to reach for the gun at one
point but we don't see that on we don't
see that and when you listen to his
final words that seems that also seems
hard to believe all right thank you very
much